okay this is very very interesting this
is in a way kind of like a Joe Rogan
covid part two this right winger Dennis
Prager
is known for Prager University which is
a YouTube channel that puts out a kind
of right wing analyzes and
interpretations of uh the world we've
heard that there are some teachers who
even play these prageru videos in
classrooms which is wholly inappropriate
Dennis Prager is sort of like this Uber
right winger he's never seen a
right-wing position he doesn't like and
he has been saying a lot of things that
don't make sense about kovid all along
Dennis Prager now has coronavirus okay
so he's doing his show from home and in
this clip there's a few things we're
going to look at Dennis Prater has been
downplaying covet all along he says in
this clip he wanted to get covered in
order to develop natural immunity and he
tells us everything's fine everything's
no big deal but he is taking five
medications including ones that are not
proven to do anything for covid and it
reminded me of the Joe Rogan thing where
Joe Rogan also said let's listen I'm
fine I felt terrible for a day or two
but I'm taking in Rogan's case I think
it was six medications plus supplements
and vitamins but this is no big deal now
of course our question was
would you do that for the flu because if
you wouldn't then clearly this is more
serious than the flu which many of these
folks deny so let's just get into the
clip there's a lot here there's a lot
here and we're going to talk in detail
about all of this okay everybody all
good I'm broadcasting from my home right
thank you so by the way what he did
there was he had a he has a cough button
if you're watching he just let out a
horrifying cough but it wasn't audible
right right at the top here
because I'm not going into the station
as I have coveted I came I was tested
positive last week
and I have been
steadily improving
at no point was I in danger of
hospitalization
I have received monoclonal
antibodies okay
that's regeneron I have of course for
years a year and a half not years I've
been taking
hydroxychloroquine from the beginning
with zinc
I've taken z-pack the
erythromycin right
as the zelinko protocol would have it I
have taken Ivermectin okay
I have done what a person should do
if one is not going to get vaccinated
it is infinitely preferable to have
natural immunity than vaccine immunity
that has not been demonstrated
and that is what I hoped for the entire
time
hence I so uh
engaged with strangers constantly
hugging them taking photos with them
knowing that I was in making myself very
susceptible to getting covered which is
indeed as bizarre as it sounded what I
wanted wow
in the hope that I would achieve natural
immunity and be taken care of by
Therapeutics that is exactly what has
happened it should have happened to the
great majority of Americans
the number of deaths in this country
owing to covid is a scandal
one day will be clear to America so I
guess he's saying the covet death toll
is exaggerated or something like that
now the truth is if we had taken a
so-called herd immunity approach like
get as many people infected as possible
the estimates are that the death toll
would be in the millions already rather
than the hundreds of thousands but where
do I want to focus today
do you take five medications for
something that's no big deal do you take
five medications include I mean these
are some some of these are serious
medications do you take this for the flu
do you take this for a cold and clearly
you don't meaning you are conceding that
this is different and more serious so
let's talk about them monoclonal
antibodies okay monoclonal antibodies
appear to be effective at reducing
hospitalization rate and the progression
of severe disease and death when a
patient has mild to moderate covet in
the most serious covid it's not clear
that the monoclonal antibodies help but
in mild to moderate covid it does seem
to prevent the progression to more
severe covid
uh so monoclonal antibodies yes that's
uh approved by emergency use remember a
standard which many of these folks say
is not sufficient for the vaccine but
they'll gladly take the monoclonal
antibodies under emergency use
authorization
um azithromycin the z-pack okay that's a
antibiotic now he calls it erythromycin
that's a different one this is
azithromat Azithromycin the uh data on
azithromycin for covid the overall
quality of evidence is low to very low
with a conclusion that azithromycin does
not result in Superior clinical
Improvement in covid patients relative
to Placebo azithromycin is generally
well tolerated and safe to use which we
know it's an antibiotic that's been
around for a long time does not seem to
do anything for covid but he's taking it
anyway okay
hydroxychloroquine now there are
instances of lots of things that you can
find with hydroxychloroquine you can
find individual so-called studies often
with sample sizes in the teens or or
dozens that may say it might work the
big picture is that the current body of
evidence does not show a clinical
benefit for prophylactic
hydroxychloroquine that's what Dennis
Prager says he has been doing is he's
been taking it prophylactically for a
year and a half
and there is a higher risk of Adverse
Events compared to a placebo or compared
to no prophylaxis so hydroxychloroquine
not unproven doesn't doesn't know
evidence it works Ivermectin okay there
is some uncertainty about whether
Ivermectin compared with a placebo or
the standard of care
reduces or increases mortality in
moderately ill-hospitalized patients and
many of the studies have a bias as well
as in Precision it's not even clear a
lot of the studies being pointed to are
acceptable there have been multiple
papers on Ivermectin withdrawn after
pre-print because they were not
rigorously done
it does not appear as though Ivermectin
uh helps treat covid he's taking zinc
now zinc okay
um high dose zinc has been studied
supplementation high dose zinc it's been
studied for colds it's been studied and
thought about for flu with covid there
is no evidence right now that there was
a significant reduction in the duration
of symptoms for people who are
supplementing zinc some studies with a
placebo arm specifically on older
patients suggest hospitalized coveted
patients seem to survive a little bit
longer with zinc it's important to know
a lot of older folks are zinc deficient
so it could be a vitamin D type
situation it's worthy of a study right
now there's no causal Association found
with zinc on covid and we can't say that
it actually helps so what what it might
be with zinc
is that you need to treat a ton a ton a
ton of people with super high dose zinc
uh and have a lot of a lot of people in
that population be zinc deficient to
then find someone who actually survives
all together because of the zinc we just
don't know it's certainly not clear
right now that there's any causal link
so that's what Prager is taking four of
the five things he's taking aren't shown
to actually do anything for kovid and
remember this is something that's not
serious anyway it's it's something
that's not serious anyway as far as he
and many many others have said so very
confusing and by the way I've gone
around hugging people and blah blah blah
blah who knows uh what the uh follow-on
effects of that are and it certainly
doesn't seem considerate to anybody else
to be doing that in the middle of a
global pandemic so that's Dennis Prager
a man that many people see as a great
thinker
as a great speaker as a great
um uh uh almost like a mage of some sort
there are people who worship this guy
and this is what he's doing taking five
medications four of which are unproven
for something that wasn't serious anyway
very very strange stuff and we'll have
more on this on our Instagram which you
can find at davidpackman show
one of our sponsors is Magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals I loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb great if you're just
trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon They're bringing
back cookies and cream They're bringing
back Maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as I do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com Pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code Pacman at checkout